watch were to do we passing attitude
would you stand up and walk out on me
lay enemy Oh leaders then I'll sing you
a song I will try not to sing
Oh
[Music]
we've only just begun to tea
Oh your lawyers not your D&C it can kiss
our bonds remember just big
with your seasoned DC
we wipe our ball
we'll keep on making
[Music]
yes we just
[Music]
his child
yes every
together
[Music]
when the takedowns come
we smile
knowing the
did you pee
we crush you in court
yes we just big
[Music]
[Music]
right
together
together
when our lawyer come
we smile
I know we know screwed you
we'll win in court and we'll come to
and yes we've just big
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry I'm late no problem
today's Molyneux and millennial right
yeah should be shop oh really - so today
[Music]
so nothing but the ghetto take your
short steps one foot at a time and keep
my head low I never let go cuz if I let
go then I'll be spineless I'm going it's
a
[Music]
ladies if you caught up in the world
while it's done I guarantee you front
the side of the budget knocking gazelle
for no reason
once I get down up in no reason it's C
with you just wanna calm down please
pause there seems like I said lay the
law down that was all black what you
wanna do I'm asking you
making your way in the world today takes
everything you've got taking a break
from all your worries sure would help a
lot
wouldn't you like to get away
[Music]
they're always glad you came
you wanna be
you wanna be
your name
[Music]
[Applause]
YouTube sent two torpedoes into our side
chief we're coming up on 700,000
subscribers on YouTube drop the bomb the
D monetization Bob over 600 videos in
the channel all of them restricted in
less than 12 minutes didn't see the
first video get to monetize for half an
hour was an hour long interview with
Dennis Prager about human nature you
know how to tell when your videos about
to get be monetized Chiefs you can tell
by how many sjw's it triggers by how
much truth is in there we didn't know
because your tubes new policies have
been so secret no email notifications
had been sent they don't name an answer
and have our emails for a week for the
very first week chief that preferred
moderator started flagging we formed
ourselves into a tight group with mugs
you know it's kind of like the old
squares and battle legacy in the
calendar like the Battle of Waterloo and
the idea was angry STW come to take down
the channel some made-up guideline
violation he decide pound and holler and
scream and sometimes that's JW go away
sometimes you wouldn't go away
sometimes I just aww he looked right in
you right under your eyes you know the
thing about honesty never he's got
lifeless eyes black eyes like a doll's
eye comes that's yes doesn't seem to be
living till he screams at you those
gender-neutral I
right when you get that terrible
high-pitched bullcrap notification your
channel turns red with a hard strike
despite of all the fighting and the
hollering YouTube comes in and it [ __ ]
appeases nobody spoke up in that first
wave you too restricted over 600 videos
I don't know how many demonetized maybe
500 I don't know how many channels
sucked down they average 6 an hour once
early morning chief I run into a friend
of mine laden from how the world works
flyer analytical type I thought he had
an uploaded a video in a while scanned
his channel to see you it will scroll up
and down on the page looking for a
content well turns out he'd been struck
down for hate speech a real mouth video
- chief a historical account of the
atrocities Japan committed against China
and World War 2 no profanity no graphic
content anyway YouTube's art and Moon
are just because it offended some
Japanese moderator you know that was the
time I was was frightened when for my
turn I'll never be dependent on YouTube
for my livelihood again
so 700 videos uploaded to our YouTube
channel only 24 enable YouTube
restricted or to monetize the rest June
29 2007 teen anyway they created the mug
club I wanna do do your Fair Spanish
ladies
farewell wanna do to you ladies of Spain
[Music]
it's a rare condition this day and age
to read in a good news on the newspaper
page love in traditions of the grand
design some people say is even harder to
buy
me so magic clew inside this
[Music]
it's the bigger love of the family
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good pass-down
[Music]
just be gentle
what do you think you're gonna make a
beverage bustle beverages keep your
liquids one hand to go by 42% Oh speak
too too much but they but they can only
do it
just eating that's right you can - I'm
gonna paint it it's handed here in
America Nevada
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a beautiful day in this
neighborhood a beautiful day for a
neighbor won't you be mine could you buy
it's a neighborly day in this beauty
would a neighborly day for this beauty
could you be mine
I have always wanted to have a neighbor
just like I always wanted to live in a
neighborhood with you so let's make the
most of this beautiful day since we're
together we might as well say would you
be mine could you be mine won't you be
my neighbor
won't you be well won't you please
please would you be my subscriber did
you enjoy this video here's the thing
your role you're here this is the end of
it so we don't care cuz you already
watched it but if you really didn't like
it and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know and subscribe to the channel
because that lets the overlords at
YouTube know that you know what you're
alright